yeah welcome to this video playing
before what for change and d6 you know
okay let's go for a row and regular open
Sicilian always be tricky for me because
I don't know it okay let's play this um
this line the cup of variation it's the
Queen t2 here or do they play a form if
all don't really know I guess a 5m
hmm I guess night 695 is the move that
normally played
hmm yeah probably i need to take it not
much choice
okay yeah this looks like and white is
not exactly having much probably this is
just equal and I think this is this is
maybe even though the the main the main
way to to play this like it's not
terribly exciting but certainly am quite
solid
mm yeah Bishop c5 just exchanging
everything
I go here he would probably take any way
in play Quincy five maybe I winning
winning winning a tempo instead of
taking everything I playing Knight c3
okay
so a five year of course if I have a
slight weakness
how to continue
came I don't really don't really know
how to how to make any substantial
progress here
looked for some really annoying news
maybe look before could be 60 B vb6
before b6 I don't know I really don't
like this sorry stupid idea play the
King 1 F 2
thinking about Bishop f1 and 92 getting
rid of the rook of course the a4 Lucas
is hanging so this isn't even isn't even
possible
look before Matt might be terribly
stupid
you know if it takes a five I can take
on one be seven this is the idea at
least night here let's go go there first
and I don't see how to do not not repeat
yeah i mean i'm worth simply i mean i
don't really see how to how to not
repeat or quigley six wins for black
yeah maybe yeah maybe I'd look at this
is really ugly yeah I am I don't know I
don't really know this opening this is
slightly slightly annoying already I
think very difficult for y2 to make any
any any constructive plan I lost a
couple of moves and then went for this
look at winter adventure and this is
probably not working at all 95 is the
calm suggestion yeah this is a good move
getting getting rid of this here this is
good actually getting getting see form
this kind of stuff this is really freeze
my position of God going before next
you
yeah this is equal ish probably I guess
what needs to improve some somewhere
before in the opening 22 heavily
something yeah very very short and
uneventful gamer but I didn't see I
couldn't really continue I was this is
good man just to lose this is a good
setup for black in the in the night off
with with with Bishop e3 and the Sun the
slow set up yeah thanks for watching